mathilde sénéchal 21 ans étudiante en
droit dans le corps des athées
international show pour faire des
chevaux plus explosifs de plus rapide
repéré par le club de la gibelotte saint
hélier toujours licenciée
la semaine je m'entraîne tout seul à
orléans du lundi au jeudi donc c'est un
peu ou à la fin c'est un peu chiant et
là je suis contente de rentrer le
vendredi c'est que je retrouve tout le
monde au stade donc je suis content
c'est ici que tout a commencé avec
daniel aubry en 2012
l'idc taille assez vite tu fous pas le
trépied en l'air mettaya taille assez
vite et rythmé 1 2 1 2 1 2 2 depuis il
fait toujours ses programmes
d'entraînement et la retrouve
régulièrement sur la piste blésoise le
duo tony blair tac tac tac voilà ça
c'est un peu mieux c'est un peu mieux
difficile yeux suffisent travail
scolairement donc faut caser les
entraînements et des moments de détente
donc tout ça ça et ensemble les
entraînements à augmenter la scolarité
et le moment de détente parce que si on
fait tout en stress et pour évacuer le
stress il ya les copains du club
partenaire d'entraînement et premiers
supporters ils sont à fond derrière ils
sont trop contents quand c'est comme ça
donc en plus sont contents de finir la
préparation avec moi généralement quand
je fais mes dernières séances assez
compliqué ballet gailly mais dit prévoir
pas tes sentiments grand jour j'ai rêve
est gênant moi je suis vraiment très
fier d'elle 2
de ce qu'elle fait c'est vraiment des
mots qui sort du coeur et je suis
vraiment admiratif c'est une battante en
compétition à se transcender et pour moi
c'est vraiment une source d'inspiration
tout un club derrière sa championne ce
dimanche pour les championnats d'europe
de cross-country objectif top 10 dans la
catégorie essais comme l'an passé
ensuite l'étudiante match de sénéchal se
focalisera sur ces partielles de droit
qui beaucoup d'ambitions pour un double
projet